[Música]
hola soy el tecno mago y hoy va a ser
diferente porque hoy voy a leer tu mente
estando a kilómetros de distancia y
gracias a internet pero para ello voy a
necesitar que tengas una hoja blanca en
mano y también un bolígrafo así que si
aún no lo tienes a tu alrededor
corre a buscarlo y cuando regreses dale
al play de nuevo
porque cuando he dicho la palabra
technomag o se lo que has pensado
sabe que es un tecno mago
pues a lo que me dedico es a combinar
los secretos de la magia que existen
desde hace miles de años con internet
para crear experiencias wow en las
empresas tanto para sus públicos
internos para sus equipos como para sus
clientes
prospera dentro de esta frase has dicho
dos cosas que me han chocado la primera
que la magia existe desde hace miles de
años pues si la magia existe desde
tiempos egipcios de hecho el primer
truco de magia del que tenemos
constancia se sitúa en la corte del
faraón keops cuando un joven mago
llamado djedi se presentó delante del
faraón y supo revivir a un animal a un
gancho lo más curioso es que desde
entonces la magia ha existido y ha
sobrevivido a lo largo de todos los años
pero la figura del mago ha ido cambiando
desde de berlín las brujas del medievo
más que el inide van en la época dorada
de la magia de vico perfil y en la
actualidad con figuras como en lomas o
hasta aplicaciones móviles como tik tok
que nos permiten crear efectos mágicos
digitales a cualquier persona con tan
sólo unos clics pero si algo nos enseña
toda esta historia es que si por una
razón los magos siempre han sobrevivido
es porque siempre se han adelantado al
avance tecnológico esta ha sido en su
clave
y esto es justamente lo que las empresas
han querido apropiarse de la magia han
querido [ __ ] de la magia de hecho
cuántos mensajes ha recibido hoy
muchísimo seguro
y las empresas lo saben y saben que
gracias a la magia pueden lograr este
efecto wow que de verdad te sorprenda y
robar durante unos segundos aunque sea
tu atención
en los últimos años he trabajado con
varias empresas para lograr este efecto
wow y hay algunas que se lo han
integrado en su adn casi te voy a dar
tres ejemplos el primer ejemplo una
empresa de cerveza es la marca guinness
que me contrató hace cinco años
para mostrar como la marca se está
modernizando así que cogí una tablet y
de la tablet mágicamente apareció la
cerveza guinness lo más increíble es que
de la imagen virtual en 3d de la cerveza
la cerveza apareció después en la
realidad otro ejemplo que a la marca de
coches quería mostrar de una forma
impactante cuántos vehículos cuántos
coches se habían vendido en ese mismo
año lo que se hacía antiguamente era el
director de marketing explicar el número
y mostrar el número pero claro cuánta
gente se acordaría eso no es el número
por eso lo que hice es juntar a todos
los equipos de kia en un gran pabellón
los mismos equipos con sus propios
teléfonos móviles consiguieron adivinar
el número de coches vendidos en ese
mismo año con un gran truco de tecno
magia con sus propios móviles
tercer ejemplo para mostrar un concepto
aún más abstracto por ejemplo el amor
que existe en una compañía pues la
empresa farmacéutica y sting también
colabore con ellos también se apropiaron
de la magia y en lugar de enseñar un
powerpoint de como el amor está en la
compañía que no sería muy efectivo lo
que hicimos es que todo el equipo de
recursos humanos empezar a [ __ ] luces
rojas del aire hasta formar un gran
corazón tecnológico en el centro de la
sala
wow si eres empresario vendedor ya
tienes claro cómo [ __ ] todos estos
secretos de la magia y empezar a
comunicar de una forma wow pero si tú no
lo eres como lo puedes aplicar en tu día
a día pues bien yo creo que en el fondo
todos tenemos algo de vendedores en
nosotros mismos acaso no te gustaría que
el próximo año te subieron el sueldo o
conseguir que el plan que tienes en
mente cada fin de semana pudiera
convencer a todos tus amigos para que lo
siguieran
para eso hoy te voy a contar 7 secretos
para que tú
también puedes despertar este efecto wow
puedas crear este efecto wow así que
vamos con el primero romper
lo que hace el mago es romper todas las
leyes de la naturaleza por ejemplo yo
como mago si tengo una pelota y dejó ir
la mano la pelota flotará en cambio tú
si tienes la pelota en la mano y dejarse
ir la mano la pelota caerá el suelo
pero claro tú no sabes los mecanismos
para que esta pelota se pueda mantener
en el aire
pero lo que puedes hacer es en lugar de
romper como hacemos los magos las leyes
de la naturaleza puede romper todas tus
rutinas en tu día a día por ejemplo al
despertar si te levantas sales de la
cama te vas a desayunar y después te vas
a la ducha mañana cambia cambia esta
rutina sal de la cama te vas a la ducha
y después vas a desayunar
o por ejemplo si para ir al trabajo
sales de casa te vas al trabajo del
punto a al punto b y siempre sigues la
misma ruta mañana cambia una parte de
esta ruta
como por arte de magia empiezas a [ __ ]
todo en nuevos estímulos todo de nuevos
sensaciones que mejorarán este efecto
wow que tiene sentido gracias a tus
sentidos
2 absorber lo que hace el mago es
absorber la imaginación de su espectador
y esto es muy interesante por ello por
ejemplo de pequeño hacía un truco de
magia que da a elegir entre una baraja
de cartas una carta
el espectador la cogía y de golpe
mágicamente la carta aparecía después en
mi bolsillo
pero lo más increíble es que al cabo de
dos semanas si alguien le pregunta a ese
espectador que había pasado el
espectador recordaba como que
simplemente había pensado en una carta y
esa carta había aparecido en su propio
bolsillo es increíble el poder que tiene
la imaginación
lo que tú haces realmente es rechazar la
imaginación de los otros es decir no no
esto no fue así pero lo que nosotros
hacemos los magos es abrazarla es
absorber la y aprovecharla para mejorar
también nuestro efecto wow así que a
partir de hoy no las rechaces abraza la
imaginación de los otros
mentir
nosotros los magos usamos la mentira
para un buen fin es decir como mejor
podamos construir este engaño a través
de la iluminación el sonido del propio
trucaje mayor y más creíble va a ser
toda esta ilusión para el espectador y
esta es la única forma en que tú como
espectador puedas crear er en la magia
y esto es muy interesante porque es algo
que hacen también las grandes marcas
marcas como redbull diciéndote redbull
te da alas o por ejemplo bambas nike
cuando te dicen que con sus zapatillas
vas a poder superar cualquier obstáculo
así que a partir de hoy tú también crea
tan bien como puedas tu propia mentira
miente para hacer el bien
cuarto ejercitar el mago está todo el
día ejercitando con un gimnasio creativo
portátil qué es
su baraja de cartas
pero claro tú no tienes en estos
momentos una baraja de cartas
o quizás sé
mira en tus bolsillos
porque en tus bolsillos o en tu mesa en
estos momentos hay tu propia baraja de
cartas tu teléfono móvil una fuente
inimaginable de sonidos imágenes vídeos
que con todos estos estímulos los puedes
conectar para crear nuevos efectos guau
en ti así que utiliza tu baraja de
cartas tu teléfono móvil
imaginar el mago imagina pero de una
forma muy especial porque imagina desde
el final al inicio es decir cuando yo
como mago
me preparo o pienso en un efecto pienso
en la imagen final que es lo que quiero
conseguir por ejemplo voy a hacer
desaparecer la estatua de la libertad
wow y desde allí el imposible pienso en
las estrategias las técnicas y
finalmente el material que necesito para
lograr el imposible
y este de hecho es un pensamiento que no
sólo pertenece a los magos
también pertenece a los grandes genios y
en nuestro tiempo
por ejemplo walt disney al construir el
primer disney world todos los directivos
se están pensando cómo hago para el que
el parking quepan el mayor número de
vehículos o como hago para que la cola
de las atracciones sea lo más rápida
posible
y walt disney les interrumpió y les dijo
no no no os estáis equivocando debemos
pensar cómo hacemos de este sitio el
lugar más mágico más feliz en la tierra
y esto cambió todo
así que imagina por el final y para
hacerlo imagínate que estás en medio de
times square de la gran manzana y hay un
gran panel luminoso delante tuyo en él
está tu foto y un gran titular esa es tu
meta visualiza esta meta a dónde quieres
llegar
y construye todo lo demás hacia atrás
sexto tomar poder nosotros los magos
sabemos que la única forma para que
funcione la magia es si tenemos el poder
de respecto delante del espectador y por
eso si vas a un espectáculo de magia
verás desde tu patio de butacas el patio
de butacas como todo parece en el
escenario normal no se lo miras desde la
óptica del mago todo está completamente
trucado kabul luz cada sonido cada
mecanismo para que esta ilusión para que
este engaño primero sea lo más
perfeccionado posible para que funcione
la ilusión en el espectador
así que tú también puedes preparar tu
universo de una forma especial preparar
tu mundo sea tu oficina o sea tu casa
para poder prevenir cualquier imprevisto
que pueda surgir
empoderar nosotros los magos sabemos que
la única forma para que el espectador
sienta de verdad la magia es
transfiriendo nuestro poder de nosotros
a ti a tú como espectador y para ello lo
que hacemos es pasar de una comunicación
lógica a una comunicación interactiva y
esto es lo mismo que han aprendido las
grandes marcas
por ejemplo cocacola ha pasado una
comunicación racional diciéndote las
características técnicas de la cocacola
del producto en sí a una comunicación
emocional que es cuando nos dice cómo
con la destapa tu felicidad a una
comunicación mágica e interactiva que es
cuando tenemos nuestra propia lata de
coca-cola en nuestras propias manos
y ya formamos parte del universo
cocacola esto sí que es magia
así que
sé lo que estás pensando
que tú también quieres vivir esta magia
así que reúne las cuatro tarjetas y vas
a escribir en cada una de las cuatro
tarjetas los cuatros secretos que más te
hayan chocado que más te hayan impactado
que hoy has aprendido te lo repito
romper absorber
mentir ejercitar imaginar
tomar el poder
empoderar y ahora sigue mis movimientos
junto a todas las tarjetas y darles la
vuelta
como en todo proceso creativo a veces
hay también caos en él así que las vamos
a romper por la mitad y vas a poner un
montón encima del otro el derecho encima
de la izquierdo o el izquierdo encima
del derecho fabuloso vas a abrir todas
las tarjetas en abanico
y vamos a representar este caos que
tiene a veces también el aprendizaje así
que vamos a [ __ ] los dos trozos que
están en el centro entre 3 y 3 los vas a
poner debajo de todo fantástico
la primera tarjeta va a ser nuestra
tarjeta amuleto esta tarjeta nos va a
guiar y es a la que nos vamos a aferrar
con todo este caos la dejamos a un lado
con la guardas en tu bolsillo
ahora salgas a [ __ ] la primera tarjeta
y la vas a poner en el centro en el
centro de todas las otras tarjetas
continuamos con el caos coge una o dos
tarjetas yo por ejemplo cojo dos pero tú
puedes [ __ ] una si quieres y mete las
también en el centro
perfecto
venga una más coge también la que está
encima de todo y también métela por el
centro
perfecto
y aún así a veces a los magos también
nos pasa que veces decimos nos va a
salir la magia no va a salir la magia
así que sigue conmigo va a salir la
magia la pasamos debajo no va a salir la
magia la lanzamos por los aires va a ser
lis la magia no va a salir la magia la
lanzamos por los aires va a salir la
magia no va a salir la magia la lanzamos
por los aires va a salir la magia no va
a salir la magia la lanzamos por los
aires va a salir la magia no va a salir
la magia y la lanzamos por los aires va
a salir la magia no va a salir la magia
y la lanzamos por los aires
pero lo más increíble es que solo te ha
quedado una única tarjeta repite hasta
que te quede uno y si le das la vuelta
y vas con tu otra mano a buscar la
tarjeta que tenías en tu bolsillo verás
como coinciden totalmente a la
perfección
muchas felicidades ahora tú ya eres mago
este secreto forma parte de tu vida ya
lo verás
[Aplausos]
[Música]